دكتور عندما أخبرت منتجنا أنه في
كل مرة تتحدث فيها على الهواء عن
فيروس كورونا ، تشعر برد فعل عنيف على
عرقك بشكل مباشر ، هل يمكنك شرح
ما يحدث
بالتأكيد ، هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي أتحدث فيها عن هذا الأمر لأنك
تعلم فقط  لم يبدو شيئًا
أردت التحدث عنه من قبل ولكنه
مهم في كل مرة أقرأ فيها غرفة ورقية
أو في قاعة المدينة أو بخلاف ذلك
أتحدث عن فيروس كورونا وأقدم
المشورة بشأن الحد من المخاطر
على الأشخاص وعائلاتهم.
أنا آكل الخفافيش يخبرني أن
أعود إلى بلدي ويقول إنه
يجب أن أعترف بأن وجهة نظره حول
شعبي الذين يتسببون في هذا الفيروس
ولدي أصدقاء وزملاء أو
أطباء وممرضات
آسيويون أمريكيون يبصقون عليهم
ونرفض أن يعاملوا من قبلهم لأنهم
من الواضح أنهم
يحملون هذا الفيروس الآن كلنا
كمحترفين صحيين نقوم بعملنا
ونمضي قدمًا ونبذل قصارى جهدنا  نحن نستوعب
هذا إذا لم ندع هذا يزعجنا
بقدر ما نستطيع ، لكنني أعتقد أن الحقيقة هي
أنه لا يجب أن يكون الأمر بهذه الطريقة
نرى قادة
دولتنا وزعماء محليين ، وكثير منهم
يتقدمون  والتحدث علانية ضد العنصرية
العنصرية وكراهية الأجانب ، ويجب على
رئيس الولايات المتحدة
فعل الشيء نفسه ، هل كلماته التي
تعتقد أنها مهمة ، أعني أنها لا تزال
تهم الكثير من الناس ، أعني أن العديد من
الناس لا يشعرون بالخدر تجاه ما
الرئيس يقول ولكن من الواضح أن الكثير من الناس
في هذا البلد ما زالوا يستمعون إليه ،
وهو يعطي ترخيصًا للكثير من
الكلمات والسلوكيات غير المقبولة ،
فهناك الملايين والملايين من
الأمريكيين الذين يعتبر الرئيس بالنسبة لهم هو
الرسول الأكثر مصداقية
وسيستخدمونها  الكلمات
وللأسف ستعيق جهودنا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالصحة العامة ، أعني أنني قلق بشأن هؤلاء
المرضى الذين لا يتبعون
نصائح أطبائهم أو ممرضاتهم لأنهم من
أصل آسيوي.  استخدام
هذه الكلمات التي تتعارض مع جميع
معايير الصحة العامة لدينا ، أعني أن منظمة
الصحة العالمية لديها
لجنة كاملة مكرسة لتسمية
الأمراض الجديدة لتجنب هذا الخوف
والوصمة والعنصرية وأتمنى
أن يستخدم الرئيس اسم  فيروس
Tsarskoe v2 وهذا المرض
Cova 19 الذي تسميه منظمة الصحة
العالمية وجميع خبراء الصحة العامة